if you're scared that you might not get
scared by netflix's horror selection
have no fear whether you're looking for
a newer release that's packed with
terror and suspense
or you're craving a spooky classic that
will bring back some nostalgia chills
we've got you covered the horror genre
is often at its best when translating
the internal to the external
turning a personal fear into a boogeyman
that anyone can relate to
in the case of gerald's game a netflix
original by horror maestro mike flanagan
the internal is externalized to an
almost absurd degree
based on the novel by stephen king
gerald's game was considered to be
entirely unfilmable
since nearly the entire story takes
place in a single room
and only follows one character both the
novel and the film tell the story of
jesse
brilliantly portrayed here by carla
gugino jesse decides to take a romantic
vacation with her husband gerald in an
effort to rekindle their flagging
relationship
unfortunately gerald has a bondage
fetish and it's so extreme that it
involves real handcuffs and some very
extensive role play to make matters
worse
gerald has a weak heart and he dies
while jesse is handcuffed to the bed
with no one else around for miles nearly
the entire story minus some flashbacks
takes place on a bed as jesse's left to
contemplate what led her to this
situation and how she can possibly
escape
it's the kind of setting that could
easily translate into an incredibly
boring cinematic experience
but gugino's powerful performance and
flanagan's steady escalation of tension
and danger
feel endlessly interesting be warned
however while gerald's game has plenty
of internal horror
anyone squeamish about gore should be
prepared for an incredibly eye-opening
climax
one of the best things about the horror
genre is the way that it can take
personal fears and make them universal
you might not know what it's like to
live in a war zone but you can probably
relate to the struggle to keep your
family safe
from an uncaring danger if it's
visualized as a monster
under the shadow follows shide a former
medical student barred from resuming her
studies because of her time as a
political activist to make things worse
shide lives in tehran during the iran
iraq war in the 1980s
which saw the city become a major target
for bombing her husband is conscripted
leaving day and her young daughter in an
apartment complex where they have to
flee to the basement as soon as they
hear the bomb siren
there also might be a gin haunting the
apartment looking to steal shide's
daughter away from her
under the shadow bear some loose
similarities to the babadook
both are about young mothers trying to
protect their child from a malevolent
supernatural entity
that might not even be real still while
the babadook feels almost
claustrophobically internal
under the shadow is painfully external
she day and her daughter might not
always have the best relationship
but every moment of their lives is made
worse by the constant looming threat of
violence
whether it's a gin or a missile there
really is something that can take
shide's daughter away
if she doesn't protect her with all her
might for plenty of people the scariest
possible situation in life has nothing
to do with the cult rituals or being
lost and frightened
in the wilderness for some people the
scariest thing in life is having to go
to a dinner party with people they don't
actually like
that seems to be the genesis behind the
invitation which follows will and his
new girlfriend kira
as they attend a dinner party hosted by
will's ex-wife
and her new boyfriend as you can
probably guess since this film was on a
list of horror movies
things go alright in slightly more
disturbing ways than they would in a wes
anderson film
what are you talking about we don't want
to go too deep into the specifics of the
plot because it would spoil some of the
fun of the movie
what we can say is that the invitation
is some of the best slow building
tension
you're likely to get from any film along
with extraordinary performances that
immediately engross you in the
character's mysterious drama
also word of warning this movie might
make you feel a little paranoid at your
next dinner party
so be sure to keep any suspicions about
the guests to yourself
sounds crazy you might have heard this
one before
a teenage girl burdened by issues at
home suddenly finds herself at the mercy
of a supernatural entity
that seems to be pushing her down a dark
and deadly path veronica sounds like a
dozen other horror movies from the
synopsis alone but plus isn't everything
in horror what sets this film apart is
the steady
versatile directing of paco plaza
probably best known to american
audiences
as a director to the original wreck the
film also boasts a wonderful and intense
lead performance from sandra s casena
if you've seen one exodus as a movie
you've seen most of them
but veronica demand your interest with
the smaller details
children with photo negatives covering
their eyes as they gaze at an eclipse
veronica using music and headphones to
briefly escape her responsibilities and
to surrogate mother for her siblings the
mutable nature of high school friendship
when veronica first dropped on netflix
plenty of sites heralded the film as one
of the scariest films ever made
while that might not be true for
everyone veronica definitely stands out
on a crowded sub-genre
and is more than worth a watch some
horror movies spend most of their run
time building to a major moment
whether that moment is an explosion of
violence a shocking plot twist that no
one saw coming or a combination of both
then there are movies like richard
shepard's the perfection a film that
starts with a wild moment
then keeps building and building until
you're so embedded in the chaos that you
can't wait to see how it all turns out
the perfection follows a pair of
classical musicians who each rose to
prominence
under the two tillage of the same
legendary teacher what begins as a
friendly rivalry soon evolves into an
absolutely unhinged game of manipulation
and violence
but all is not as it seems by the time
the perfection is over
it becomes a tale of two women going to
great lens to ensure their freedom
no matter what the cost because the
system that took the minister nothing
but chewed them up and spit them out
featuring a couple of truly stunning
twists and anchored by delightfully wild
performances from allison williams
and logan browning the perfection is one
of the great and sanchorus successes of
recent years
and deserves much more attention few
things are more uncomfortable than being
trapped in a social situation
with someone who's either oblivious or
intent on ignoring social
cues that could be the line of thinking
that led to creep a found footage horror
movie about a videographer named aaron
played by patrick bryce who finds
himself
working for the very strange and very
creepy joseph
who was perfectly portrayed by mark du
place aaron's been asked to film a
series of messages for joseph's unborn
son before he succumbs to terminal
cancer
and aaron's been offered enough money to
offset some of joseph's odd behavior
however things start to go off the rails
when joseph pulls out a wolf mask
and becomes a character he calls peach
fuzz hello my name is peach first
i might look like a eat you up as with
most found footage horror movies there
are moments that might make you scream
at your screen to turn off the camera
and start running
nevertheless duplex and bryce who also
wrote the movie together
have enough chemistry that you
understand why aaron sticks around it's
not a film that's likely to convince a
vowed found footage haters to embrace
the subgenre but it's definitely one of
the best
and most unusual no budget horror movies
around it's also filled with plenty of
dark humor and serious scares
sorry keep doing that when it comes to
the faux chorus sub genre the original
the wicker man is the gold standard
against which all other films are
measured and it's often a joy to see how
various other movies refund and pay
tribute to that classic
one thing worth noting about the wicker
man is of course that it's a slow burn
film that waits until almost the very
end to reveal the full horror
of summer isle and its people if you're
looking for a film that plays with some
of the same ideas but leans much harder
into the horror elements gareth evans
apostle is perfect for you
the film follows thomas a man who visits
an island off the coast of wales
in search of his missing sister it's
there that he finds a cult driven by a
charismatic leader who is convinced of
the island's mythology
which says a blood sacrifice is
necessary to make it the lush green
paradise it seems to be now
what begins as a somewhat
straightforward mystery surrounding the
cult
soon turns much more horrific as thomas
learns that the folk stories about the
island are truer than he realized
apostle may not live up to the wicked
man in terms of shia aura but it
succeeds in different ways because it's
willing to go further and deeper with
its folk horror mythos the result is an
intense haunting movie
driven by two celely performances from
dan stevens and michael sheen
sometimes you just have to go with a
classic whether you've been browsing for
hours unsure of what to watch
or you're just eager for some horror
movie comfort food in that regard it
doesn't get much better than poltergeist
this classic story of a family who moves
into a new home and quickly finds they
aren't alone
holds up remarkably well thanks to no
small part to how completely human it
feels
just about everyone can identify with at
least one member of the freeling family
whether you identify with their
individual goals and desires or with the
things that terrify them
and that roots the movie in a sense of
reality that still reaches out and grabs
you
of course even if that's not why you're
watching poltergeist you'll still find
plenty of things to love about it the
scares in the film from skeletons and
the muddy earth to the creepy clown doll
are still effective nearly 40 years
after the film was first released the
movie is also packed with great acting
memorable characters
and snappy dialogue your mind hanging
back
you're jamming my frequencies so whether
you've seen it a dozen times or you're
arriving at it for the first time
holds a guide to the type of classic
film that can still feel brand new
decades after it first hit theaters
at this point the blumhouse productions
has carved out an undeniable niche in
the cinematic marketplace by producing
low budget high concept horror films
whether they're producing critical and
commercial smashes like get out
or slightly less popular horror scene
calls like amityville the awakening
you can pretty much count on a movie
produced by plum house to at least be
interesting
luckily sweetheart lands much closer to
get out than amityville on the blumhouse
quality spectrum
sweetheart tells the story of jennifer a
woman who washes up on a seemingly
deserted island after a storm
the island appears to have plenty of
food and resources for shelter
but there are also clear indications
that other castaways have washed up on
its shore in the past
as jennifer explores the island the film
is almost entirely dialogue free
there's no narration and jennifer
doesn't have a convenient habit of
talking out loud while puzzling things
out
instead sweetheart relies almost
entirely on kia c
clemens's exceptional physical acting
letting the camera simply follow her as
she figures out whether or not she's
alone on the island
and whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing throw in an ominous synth heavy
score and you've got an exceedingly
solid horror flick that's full of
surprises
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one